PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Every
week on Google Cloud Labs,
we discuss a different
lab and go over
what you would learn
when you take a lab.
But what is Qwiklabs, and how
can it be helpful for you?
A Qwiklab is an online
learning environment
along with a set of
instructions to walk you
through a live, real-world,
and scenario-based use
case without needing
an account on GCP.
In a lab, you will have access
to the actual environment
you want to learn about--
not a simulation or
demo environment.
You can access the
lab environment
from anywhere on the internet
using a standard browser.
So how do you take a lab?
First, get started by
either creating an account
or signing in.
Find labs by browsing
the Qwiklabs Quest
or clicking on the Lab
Catalog and then the Lab tab.
The Lab tab lets you scroll
through all the available labs.
Read more about
a lab by clicking
on the lab of your choice.
The Lab page opens
to the Lab menu page.
The timer located next
to the Start Lab button
shows the total time
that resources will be
made available to take the lab.
The lab will end after the
timer finishes counting down.
To begin a lab, click
the Start Lab button.
The lab will not start until
you have selected the Start Lab
button and entered the
appropriate credits
or token code.
The cost of the lab is
indicated in credits.
Some labs are free and
require no credits.
Each dollar spent
buys one credit.
Labs vary in number
of credits required.
When you are finished with the
lab, click the End Lab button
and leave a review.
You'll notice something else in
Qwiklabs, and that is quests.
Qwiklab Quests are introductory
and advanced learning pads
that consist of collection of
labs organized by technologies,
specific cloud services,
and practical use cases.
Completion of the required labs
that are part of Qwiklabs Quest
will earn you badges
that recognize
your hands-on experience.
Your Qwiklabs Quest
badges will be
a permanent part of your
Qwiklabs account and profile.
Referencing your
accomplishments can be
a positive mark of distinction.
You're encouraged to share your
achievements on social media.
For example, you can
do this by adding
a link on your LinkedIn
profile pointing to your badge.
There are many labs on Qwiklabs.
Let us know in comments below
which one you are taking
and how it went.
Thank you for
watching, and whenever
you are ready to sign
up, we are giving you
a $300 credit for GCP.
Just click on the link
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]